good evening mother welcome to
Pittsburgh on our center it's good to be
back and it's good but it's Pride months
which of course used to be about
celebrating gay rights and quite right
too but it's now mostly about
advertising campaigns by Brands
celebrating their own righteousness
big businesses love to Signal their
virtue in English-speaking countries
where gay rights have been hard fought
and hard earned but not so much in the
Middle East where it's often illegal and
punishable by death and with everything
from Burgers to Banks and beers now
bedecked in the rainbow flag companies
have to work a little bit harder to
prove just how virtuous they are glamor
magazine has chosen to make Logan Brown
as pride month cover star I'm a pregnant
trans man and I do exist he said no
matter what anyone says I'm living proof
let me prove a what
Logan is living proof that biological
women can get pregnant there's hundreds
of biological women do every single year
that's it that's that's all this proves
this is precisely where this movement
loses everyone with a shred of Common
Sense
it's not about trans people it really
isn't most people watching us have
probably never even met a trans person
most people including me who have just
want equal rights and respect that
anybody who suffers from gender dysmoria
who genuinely believes they're born into
the wrong body this is about
increasingly hysterical campaign to make
us all believe the sky is green and the
grass is blue that anyone who disagrees
is a hateful transphobe and a bigot it's
a campaign that petrifies politicians
leads us to the remarkable position that
the two opposition leaders in British
politics now make statements like this
a woman can have a penis
look I'm not but
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
you know sorry I'll get this indigenous
no no no it's just no no I just
can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um listen I've made it really clear that
if people
um uh the vast majority people will have
the same gender as their biological sex
but a small number one so a woman can
have a penis well quite clearly
quite clearly a woman can have a penis I
mean that happened before it went away
and I spent the whole week I was in
France mulling over the answer and
concluded it was a completely stupid
thing to say wasn't it can you imagine
if I said 10 years ago the British
politics would pivot on the question of
whether women have penises or that the
most terrifying question in the world
would be what is a woman
documentary of that name what is a woman
calmly eviscerates his absurdity by
allowing the people to advance the
loneliest arguments to tie themselves in
their own knots
please if one person could tell me what
a woman is
but not for women we ask you to leave
what is that a woman is not anything in
particular there is not one particular
thing it could be many things to many
people some women have penises right
some men have vaginas women only know
what women are are you a cat no can you
tell me what a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is I'm
a biological woman that medically
transitioned to appear like a male I
will never be a man the interview is
over let's turn off the cameras excuse
me I just wanted to know what is a woman
and you're not gonna find out
well that documentary was posted to
Twitter at the end of last week so it
could be seen far and wide for free to
Mark its anniversary and a sign of these
fevered times it was censored for the
crime of misgendering
misgendering
well Twitter's new owner Elon Musk
personally intervened and then
recommended the film to his gazillions
of followers and in a second sign of our
times the Tweet promoting the film has
now been viewed
172 million times so the biggest film in
the world right now isn't Little Mermaid
Spider-Man well it is Fast and Furious
it's what is a Woman by Matt Walsh which
I think shows the level of Shear
exasperation there is at this Relentless
campaign to subvert reality and Bully
anybody who refuses to go along with it
but the avoidance of Doubt a woman is an
adult human female that's it beginning
and end the percentage of women with
penises
is zero
well the daily Maguire's Matt Walsh the
filmmaker of the year right now uh joins
me Matt well congratulations I mean the
biggest movie in the world
thank you I appreciate that uh it's been
a staggering week for you I mean this it
was a great film when I watched it
originally uh because it just basically
kept asking the same question I've been
asking but so for the last year uh but
it's a question which flummox is
everyone from Supreme Court Justices to
male politicians here to anyone you care
to think of in public life
um when you put it on Twitter and then
it got suppressed and then Elon Musk
intervened what was your feeling about
that whole process
well when they first when they first
decided to censor it it was kind of this
feeling of oh well here we go again
because this is what we're used to from
uh from Big Tech it's you know every
single big Tech platform is run by the
radical far left and especially on this
particular issue
um they they don't want you to talk
about it they don't want to acknowledge
there are basic truths that aren't
allowed to be discussed we were just
demonetized by YouTube on misgendering
grounds you know just a couple of weeks
ago we thought that Twitter would be
different under Elon Musk and then they
kind of pulled the rug out up from under
us and at first for me it was sort of
this okay well I guess Twitter is the
same as all the rest of them until Elon
Musk as you say intervened and uh next
thing you know where there are
resignations and all these sort of thing
happening happening over at Twitter in
their uh in their brand safety
department
um which which makes it clear that uh
that no in fact Twitter is the one
exception it's the one major big Tech
platform where free speech is allowed so
I was I was happy that of course how it
worked out but also that this film on
top of dealing with the um with the
gender under issue also could you know
succeed in really a victory for free
speech I think it's a really important
Victory Free Speech because if if it had
gone the other way and Twitter had
decided to keep this film censored then
that would set a really dangerous
precedent I think for uh all the other
plots yeah talk about a question Elon
Musk said this in reply to someone who
tweeted him this was a mistake by many
people at Twitter talking about the
suppression of your film it's definitely
allowed whether or not you agree with
using someone's preferred pronouns not
doing so is that most rude and certainly
breaks no laws I should know that I do
personally use someone's preferred
pronouns just as I use someone's
preferred name simply from the
standpoint of good manners however the
same reason I object to Rude Behavior
ostracism or threats of violence is the
wrong pronoun or name is used which I
think is a pretty reasonable position I
mean is that a position you would share
not I mean I don't personally share that
position I'm not going to use preferred
pronouns I'm going to use the pronouns
that are that are accurate and I just
reject the concept of preferred pronouns
uh you know you can prefer whatever
pronoun you want or whatever adverb or
you know noun you want but that doesn't
mean that I have to use it you don't get
to put words in my mouth however uh the
the position that Elon Musk has on this
is uh you know it's a position a lot of
people have and at the very least it
respects free speech so this is what
he's going to do but you can say what
you want because you can't force someone
else to share your perceptions that's
what the preferred pronoun thing is all
about yeah you know they're trying to
not only put words in your mouth they
want you to affirm their perception of
reality and uh the idea that we would be
forced to do that either legally or even
according to the um terms of service of
a big Tech platform it's just uh it's
just insane what it is and of course the
argument that uses was offensive but of
course the whole point of free speech
really at its Hearts is that you should
be allowed to offend people I mean
that's the point of free speech it's not
that everyone agrees with each other
it's that you should be able to be
vehemently disagree or be offensive or
rude if you want and people should be
able to tolerate that because that's
what happens in a free Society with a
thriving democracy that believes in free
speech
yeah I and that is the importance of
Race Free Speech and like I said a lot
of this story is is about a victory for
free speech which is really important
but I also want to note that you know
what's happening here is on is on an
even deeper level because
um on the left what they're trying to
shut down it isn't just
speech generally and they are trying to
shut down speech but they're trying to
shut down true speech so it's not just
speech it's it's in particular basic
fundamental truths of life that they're
trying to stop us from saying and that
makes it all the more uh dangerous and
egregious I mean your issue with YouTube
was they demonetize your Effects of You
by saying that you had misgendered Dylan
Mulvaney who's this transgender
influencer that of course has created
Bud light's uh Revenue by taking part in
a PR stunt for them which enraged the
the core customers at Bud Light
um what did that whole thing tell you I
mean a what happened to you guys in
terms of of the way YouTube responded
but also about what happened to Bud
Light
yeah I think it shows that people are as
far as Bud Light goes people are
exhausted by this uh the left you know
they were able to run roughshod over the
culture in in Western culture generally
for years and I guess they assumed that
there would never be any there'd be
never be any pushback and they kept
going and kept going until normal people
just finally had enough of it and I wish
we had enough of it much sooner but uh
but it but at least now finally that's
uh you know a line is being drawn and I
think one of those lines is when you're
trying to get people again trying to
force them to affirm and celebrate
something that's just not true uh at a
certain point I think it's uh it's just
it's too far for the average person
that's what we're seeing now this is not
display what the left says you know this
pushback against uh LGBT pride and
against the transit of kids this is not
some Sinister right-wing well-funded uh
conspiracy this is really a this is a
Groundswell thing this is this is
Grassroots these are just normal people
who had enough of it yeah I completely
agree and then Dylan Mulvaney's case I
mean Dylan Mulvaney identified as a gay
man until last year and a lot of women
have been genuinely outraged that Dylan
Mulvaney has been putting out these
videos effectively mocking women
actually if you look at them and that's
been my problem with what Dylan Mulvaney
has done so dilemma already can can call
herself whatever she wants I don't care
um what she can't do I don't think is
make millions of dollars mocking the
concept of Womanhood when until last
year she identified as a as a gay man
and it's clearly a biological male
and it's also the irony that we hear so
much about the dangers of appropriation
these days uh even when it comes to
things like Halloween costumes where
someone is clearly just having fun and
they put on a Native American Halloween
costume whatever it may be we're told
that that's uh that's horrifically
racist and it's it's demonizing and it's
a caricature of the person here well
well that's that's exactly what Dylan
mulvania is doing he's uh he's making a
caricature of Womanhood
this cover of Glamor magazine involving
uh Logan Brown who is a trans man
appearing to be a pregnant man on the
cover but of course Logan Brown is a
biological female uh so it's actually a
pregnant female that we're looking at on
the cover when a a magazine a
mass-market mass selling women's
magazine like glamor does that to
celebrate pride month what does that say
about where we've come to as a society
well I tell you one thing it actually
says it makes the the opposite of the
point they're trying to make because the
point it actually makes is that women
are still women no matter how they
identify I mean I read that article and
they're making a big deal about you know
Logan Brown was saying well yes uh I
exist I'm I'm pregnant this is this is
real I know it's blowing people's minds
well no it doesn't blow anyone's mind we
know that you're a woman even if you cut
your hair short and you give yourself a
different name you're still a woman you
still have the biological function and
capacity of a woman so that's actually
what it proves is that these biologists
this biological identity is inherent
it's immutable
um you can't get rid of it you just are
who you are no matter how you identify
no that's not the point that we're
trying to make but to me that's that's
uh that's what it proves that even a
quote-unquote trans man can still get
pregnant proves that you know she's a
woman we've seen as I said Bud Light
we've seen the revenue collapsing after
the dilemaldani thing we've seen Target
a big supermarket chain in America
suffering similar problems after really
going very hard on Pride merchandise in
the children's departments we've seen
your film try to be canceled and then
bouncing back within days to become the
most watched film in the world I'm
getting a gut feeling Matt the the woke
worm is turning the common sense is
beginning to win the day and it's
because the majority of people who've
been silent and been cowed into silence
are beginning to find their Collective
voices and acting
I think that's exactly what happened and
that's something that even when we were
filming was a woman which goes back you
know we were filming it in 2021 a large
part of 2021 and uh you know I can
remember going around the streets and in
various different cities and doing this
man on the street interviews with people
talking about these issues with them you
know what is a woman how do you define
Womanhood and people were just the
average person on the street was
terrified to even discuss the issue
especially on camera I think that if we
were to do that part of the film again
right now I think we would get
um a different kind of response I think
there'd be a lot more people willing to
talk about this because I do I agree
people are finding their voice uh it
everyone has always known that this is
that this is crazy the idea that Sexes
can be changed and all of that people
know that it's crazy but they've been
they've been uh you know cowed into
silence and all it took was just to
realize that you know it's okay you can
speak up and say what you know is true
and once that starts happening I think
it builds momentum and I think the left
is really worried about that yeah
sometimes if you want to know it's
raining just open the window and have a
look when it's raining and you'll see
rain and the moment you start to deny
that is where the trouble starts Matt
Walsh congratulations on having this
monster film you're you're bigger than
Spielberg right now I'll take my hat off
to you
really appreciate it thank you